have you guys ever heard about dali 2
dali is an ai system that works mainly
on image processing it creates realistic
images for you from text description
this is the famous ai model dolly 2 can
make realistic edits to existing images
using natural language processing hey
everyone before diving into today's
topic please make sure you subscribe to
our channel and press the bell icon to
never miss an update
in all these years you guys might have
heard about artificial intelligence and
number of times now let us understand
what artificial intelligence is actually
about
so what's in for you
first let's discuss what exactly is
artificial intelligence next we will
cover different types of artificial
intelligence then comes interesting
concept phases of artificial
intelligence following that we will look
at branches of artificial intelligence
then we will talk about ai in daily life
finally the future of artificial
intelligence will be discussed
before moving forward let me ask you a
question which is the best ai technology
that you guys have ever come across let
me know in the comment section
moving on
first let us see what artificial
intelligence is
the term
artificial intelligence was first coined
by john mccarthy in 1950s
mccarthy established a lab for
artificial intelligence at stanford
university where he developed the first
iterations of a self-driving car
artificial intelligence is a technique
of turning a computer-based robot to
work and act like humans
siri
alexa recommendations from companies
like flipkart and amazon and
self-driving cars like tesla all this
work is based on ai
according to
novik and russell the behavior that
defines ai is thinking like a human
acting like a human rational thinking
and rational acting
in 1950s alan turing conducted an
interesting experiment that
differentiated between machines and
human he considered a machine a human
and an interrogator in his experiment
here the interrogator is aware that one
among them is a human being his job is
to identify the human based on the
answer if the interrogator fails in the
process the computer or the machine
successfully acts like a human
now we are we are aware of what is
artificial intelligence
now let us see
types in it
based on functionality there are four
types of ai
and the first type is reactive machine
reactive machine is the most common type
of artificial intelligence that doesn't
keep memories or make decisions based on
past experiences it only functions with
current data they are provided with
certain tasks and cannot go beyond them
ibm's deep blue once defeated chess
grandmaster gary casper is a reactive
machine that uses the chessboard pieces
and reacts to them its action is based
on the current move and past experience
doesn't
matter and second type is limited memory
limited memory is completely different
from reactive memory because it makes
decisions based on past experiences but
they can use it only for a specific
amount of time and it cannot be fed into
their library as past experience the
best example is self-driving cars it
records the recent movement of other
nearby cars
and third is theory of mind
it is ai's cutting edge class of
technology that only exist in concept a
deep grasp of how the people and things
in an environment can change feelings
and behavior is necessary for this form
of ai it must understand people's
emotion and feelings
even though many ai are of this type
work is not fully completed in this
field
sophia from hanson robotics is the best
example where the theory of mind ai was
implemented cameras present in sofia's
eye combine with computer algorithms
permits hard to see she can sustain eye
contact recognize individuals and follow
faces it looks like human
next comes self awareness these machines
are still under experiment so all the
things regarding it are completely
hypothetical such systems will be
smarter than human and with their own
emotions and strategies it will
understand others feelings and in
addition to it it will have its own
feelings this is the ultimate type of ai
only the future can answer about its
success story
these are all the important types of
artificial intelligence next let's move
on and understand phases of ai
there are three important phases of ai
one is narrow intelligence general
intelligence and third is super
intelligence first let us see what is
narrow intelligence
narrow ai is commonly referred to as
weak ai is limited to program in small
or narrow tasks it is subjected to
limited abilities this has widely
occupied our day-to-day life siri
amazon's alexa google translate google's
translation work on natural language
processing which we will discuss later
ibm's watson super computer is another
example of narrow ai it is named after
the founder and ceo of ibm thomson j
watson it uses machine learning natural
language processing and cooperative
computing to process information
and answer queries
general ai also referred to as strong ai
is capable of learning and comprehending
any intellectual endeavor that a person
is capable of it enables a machine to
use
knowledge and abilities in various
situations ai researchers have not yet
developed strong ai
they would have to find a method to
program computers with the complete
range of cognitive abilities with
necessary consciousness companies like
microsoft are investing heavily in this
technology
tna 2 is a supercomputer that was
developed by china's national university
of defense technology it holds the
record of 33.86
petaflops per second although that
sounds exciting the human brain is
estimated to be capable of one example
that is a billion calculations per
second
and last comes super intelligent it
performs tasks better than any human
being this is the current position of
the world in the field of artificial
intelligence this means we are in the
stage of developing super intelligence
ai super ai overtakes human intelligence
and can perform tasks better than any
human the concept of artificial super
intelligence sees ai evolved to be so
akin to human sentiments and experiences
that it doesn't merely understand them
it also evokes emotions needs beliefs
and desires of its own its existence is
all hypothetical some of the critical
characteristics of super ai includes
thinking solving puzzles making
judgments and decisions on its own hope
to see this development very soon these
are the faces of ai let us now cover
different branches of artificial
intelligence
so first is machine learning
then comes deep learning
after that robotics and finally natural
language processing first let us learn
machine learning
you might have heard about machine
learning many times it is a powerful
branch of artificial intelligence this
amazing technology help computer system
learn and improve from experiences by
developing computer programs that can
automatically access data and perform
tasks via predictions and directions
when you order something very constantly
on amazon it will show recommendations
on similar products you can check out
many videos related to machine learning
from simply learn machine learning and
the rapid advancement of artificial
intelligence make this all possible
next is deep learning deep learning can
be considered as a subdivision of
machine learning it is a field that is
based on learning and improving on its
own by examining different computer
algorithms deep learning works with
artificial neural networks which are
designed to
imitate how human think and learn deep
learning is used in image processing
language translation speak recognition
it can be used to solve any
pattern recognition problem and without
human intervention
next comes
robotics it is a branch of ai that
comprises electrical engineering
mechanical engineering and computer
science the objective of robotic is to
create intelligent machines which will
make human
work like robot say some will be like
humans and others will be in the form of
robotic process automation and many more
next is
natural language processing
natural language processing also known
as nlp is the area of artificial
intelligence that enables machines to
read and comprehend meaning from human
languages natural language processing
will help to connect the gap between
human communications and digital data
this is all about branches of artificial
intelligence
moving on to artificial intelligence in
day-to-day life
education even though the education
industry is the one most influenced by
humans artificial intelligence has also
started to establish itself there this
gradual adoption of ai has helped
faculty members become more productive
and
refocus their attention on students
rather than office or administrative
task even in the field of education
artificial intelligence can assist
educators with non-educational tasks
like task related duties facilitating
and automating personalized messages to
students back office tasks like grading
paperwork organizing and facilitating
parent and guardian interactions regular
issue feedback facilitating managing
enrollment courses etc
e-commerce artificial intelligence
technology makes recommendations engine
possible allowing you to interact with
your customers more efficiently their
browsing history preferences and
interest are considered while making
these recommendations it helps you build
stronger bonds with your clients and
increases brand loyalty chatbots and
virtual shopping assistance enhance the
user experience for online shoppers the
dialogue uses natural language
processing to sound as natural and
intimate
additionally these assistants
can interact with your consumers in real
time
next comes lifestyle when it comes to
driving in any environment and object
detection to prevent accidents
automakers like toyota audi volvo and
tesla uses machine learning to train
computers to think and evolve like
people face recognition algorithms are
used by our favorite devices including
phones laptops and personal computers to
detect and identify users to grant safe
access face recognition is most popular
artificial intelligence
used outside of personal use even in
highly secure settings in many
businesses
robotics another area where artificial
intelligence applications are frequently
applied in robotics ai powered robots
employ real time updates to detect
obstructions in their path and
instantaneously design their routes it
can be applied to transporting
commodities in warehouses factories and
hospitals cleaning huge equipments in
offices
inventory control
healthcare numerous uses of artificial
intelligence are found in the healthcare
industry building advanced devices that
can detect diseases and identify cancer
cells uses ai applications to ensure
early diagnose artificial intelligence
can assist in analyzing chronic diseases
with lab and other medical data ai
employs a combination of medical
knowledge and historical data to find
new medications
the gaming industry is another area
where ai technologies have gained
popularity ai can be utilized to develop
intelligent human-like and pcs that
communicate with players it can also be
used to forecast human behavior to
improve game design and testing the 2014
alien isolation video game used ai to
follow the player around at all times
two artificial intelligence systems are
used in the game the director ai who
frequently knows where you are and the
alien ai which is controlled by sensors
and behaviors and persistently pursues
the player these are all the important
applications of artificial intelligence
we have covered finally we are going to
see the future of artificial
intelligence
elite forms there is a real evidence
based transition from artificial
intelligence according to 61 percent of
respondents to a new deloitte insight
report aei will significantly change
their industry in the coming three to
five years additionally adoption is
significant for each firm with 53
percent of those surveyed investing more
than 20 million dollars in ai personnel
and technology in the previous year it
is
now without a question that ai is
becoming more and more integral to
company operations and even strategies
ai can ultimately produce more
employment than fewer if there is an
investment at all levels from education
to the business sector and government
organizations anywhere that focuses on
training and upskilling employees
in reality major companies are ready to
invest regularly in ai
in early major companies are already
investing regularly in ai technologies
at a rate of 90 percent businesses have
used ai driven technologies in some
capacity claim higher productivity rates
more than half of them
given that ai will have such broad
effects across numerous industries it is
also a wonderful area to concentrate
your efforts on if you want to advance
your career or boost the competitiveness
of your professional profile many
assessments of the top job market
talents for 2018 place ai and machine
learning at the top over the next five
years there will be likely
71 percent growth in the number of jobs
requiring ai or machine learning
expertise no matter how we feel about it
ai is undoubtedly here to stay we need
to adjust to this technology
thank you for watching the video have a
great day happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified click here